nous sommes au coeur de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne au milieu
de la route sur les hauteurs de la ville
occupée de doniette l'armée ukrainienne
attaque les positions russes
chaque tir compte les artilleurs doivent
être rapides et efficaces et se mettre à
couvert rapidement le système grade
n'est pas un lance-roquette de précision
il date de l'époque soviétique l'armée
ukrainienne en possède une centaine cinq
fois moins que la Russie le grade a été
créé pour neutraliser l'ennemi sur une
surface carré autrement dit nous
n'atteignons pas des cibles uniques mais
une zone entière cette seule machine
peut couvrir une superficie de 6
hectares il est actuellement chargé de
40 au but d'artillerie propulsés par
fusée action de fragmentation le système
est à longue portée il frappe à une
distance allant jusqu'à 20 km
[Musique]
la différence Kiev compte sur
l'équipement
occidental pour des frappes de précision
grâce à nos partenaires qui nous aident
désormais en plus des systèmes sur
lesquels nous travaillons l'aide des
États qui nous aident à vaincre les
Russes nous avons reçu un équipement
plus précis et plus efficace nous les en
remercions donc
nous passons dans les tranchées d'où la
59e brigade utilise ce Hobbit surf
fourni par les États-Unis un canon léger
particulièrement apprécié pour sa
facilité de manœuvre peu d'hommes sont
nécessaires pour l'activer et les obus
équipés de GPS permettent des frappes de
précision
[Musique]
les soldats Ukrainiens savent qu'ils
sont en désavantage numérique et
matériels
on est ici depuis longtemps
on est arrivé un peu avant la nouvelle
année
on se bat et on peut dire constamment
ces dernières semaines les combats se
sont intensifiés dans la région de
doniak mais les artilleurs savent que
leur frappe sont essentielles pour
percer les défenses russes et envisager
un succès de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne